This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Ronnie Johnson still remembers the first time he went underground. He and a handful of other coal miners piled into a little trailer and descended into the mine. We were going down through there hitting the bumps and running over little rocks and stuff. And I remember laying in that little trailer and the roof was actually so close to me that the build of my heart had with almost 50 root. When they got down to the bottom, Ronnie's boss handed him a wrench and told him to open a nearby water line, but someone had forgotten to cut the water off.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。罗尼·约翰逊依然记得他第一次下井的情景。他和另外几个煤矿工人挤进一个小拖车里，缓缓驶入矿井。“我们当时正顺着轨道往下走，一路上磕磕绊绊的，轧过各种小石头。我记得自己躺在那个小拖车里，矿顶离我实在是太近了，我的心跳得几乎快要撞到喉咙口了。”当他们到达井底时，罗尼的上司递给他一把扳手，让他打开附近的一根水管，但当时有人忘记把总闸关上了。
The water just started spraying me. It just sprayed all in my face and all over me out of something wet and it's like I just like fell up against the real you know the wall or cold and I thought to myself what have I done. As a new minor in a dangerous industry Ronnie had to go through an intensive orientation process before this first trip underground. That's producer Irene Zhorov. Ronnie is actually my partner's father. He lives in Northern Alabama, and on a recent visit as the family cooked dinner, Ronnie and I went out to his workshop, where he
水一下子就朝我喷了过来。水直直地喷在我的脸上和身上，从那些湿漉漉的东西里喷出来，我感觉自己一下子撞到了真正的墙壁还是煤壁上，我心里想：我这到底是在干什么。作为一名身处危险行业的煤矿新人，罗尼在第一次下井之前必须经历严格的入职培训流程。这是节目制作人伊琳·若罗夫。罗尼其实是我伴侣的父亲。他住在阿拉巴马州北部，就在不久前的一次探亲时，趁着家人在做晚饭，罗尼和我一起去了他的工作室，他
likes to sit and smoke, with only the dogs and cicadas for company. He told me about how he sat through 40 hours of training and safety classes before going down into the mines. At the end, he was issued a hard hat that identified him as a rookie. The hard hat was yellow. It was like you stood out from here to the road, you know. It was terrible. It was terrible. Was it terrible because you'd get like crap from the other men? Oh yeah, yeah. Everybody knew you were a rookie, you know.
喜欢坐在那里抽烟，只有几只狗和蝉陪伴着他。他告诉我，在下井之前，他是如何坐着完成了40个小时的培训和安全课程的。最后，他领到了一顶安全帽，这顶安全帽表明他是个新手。安全帽是黄色的。“那感觉就像是你从这儿一直显眼到大马路一样，你知道的。太糟糕了。简直糟透了。”是因为这帽子让你免不了要被其他人嘲笑吗？“哦，对，对。所有人都知道你是个新手，你知道的。”
And just, you know, practical jokes. Just nothing serious, but. In addition to this terrible yellow hard hat, the safety man at his mind also gave him a sticker. Yeah, it was this sticker right here. It's a red rhombus about two by two inches with a reflective white center. ABC and says always be careful.
还有就是，你知道的，各种恶作剧。虽然没什么大不了的，不过……除了这顶糟糕的黄色安全帽，他矿上的安全员还给了他一张贴纸。“对，就是这张贴纸。这是一个大约两英寸见方的红色菱形，中间带有一块反光白色区域。上面写着ABC，意思是‘时刻保持谨慎’（Always Be Careful）。”
But ABC was a company named Alabama byproducts Corporation. Ronnie got a few of these stickers back then. He put one in a box and one on his brand new yellow hat. This was just the beginning of Ronnie's sticker collecting. After 34 years as a minor, he now has several photo albums filled with thousands of stickers. Some are inside jokes. Some commemorate big events at work.
但ABC其实是一家名为“阿拉巴马副产品公司”（Alabama Byproducts Corporation）的企业。罗尼当年收集了好几张这种贴纸。他把一张放进了盒子里，另一张贴在了他崭新的黄色安全帽上。这仅仅是罗尼收集贴纸生涯的开始。在当了34年矿工之后，他现在已经拥有好几本塞满了成千上万张贴纸的照片册。有些贴纸是内部笑话。有些则是为了纪念工作中发生的重大事件。
Lots of other coal miners across the country have collections just like Ronnie's. Miners use these stickers for safety and for communication and as a kind of currency down in the mines. It was just what coal miners did, you know. Tits collect baseball cars, you know coal mines, you know that's all you had really to collect, you know, was coal mines stickers, so.
全国各地的许多其他煤矿工人也有着和罗尼一样的收藏。矿工们使用这些贴纸来保障安全、进行交流，甚至把它当作矿井下的一种硬通货。“这不过就是煤矿工人们常做的事，你知道的。就像别人收集棒球卡一样，你知道，煤矿里唯一真正能收集的东西，你知道的，也就是煤矿贴纸了，所以。”
One of the darkest of all working environments, underground mines. Since the beginning of underground mining, one of the biggest dangers in the workplace has been the darkness. Coal miners of today would shudder at the thought of using some of the early methods of coal mine illumination. Well into the era of industrial society, miners were still using open flames as their only source of light. The darkness makes accidents more likely, and even though technology has improved to make mines brighter and safer, it's still an issue. The culture of mining to a certain degree has been shaped by the level of risk involved.
地下矿井是所有工作环境中最为黑暗的地方之一。自从地下采矿出现以来，工作场所面临的最大危险之一就是黑暗。如今的煤矿工人一想到要使用早期煤矿照明的一些方法，就会不寒而栗。直到工业社会时期，矿工们依然在使用明火作为他们唯一的光源。黑暗使得事故更容易发生，尽管现代技术已经让矿井变得更加明亮、更加安全，但这依然是一个问题。在某种程度上，采矿文化正是由其中涉及的风险水平所塑造的。
Work cultures have very strong cultures, especially ones that face danger, like mining, firefighting, police work, the military, deep sea fishing, et cetera. This is Elaine Cullen. She's an occupational ethnographer, and she spent a lot of time with miners, like actually down in the mines with them.
职业文化往往有着非常强烈的特征，尤其是那些面临危险的行业，比如采矿业、消防、警务、军队、深海捕鱼等等。这位是伊莱恩·库伦。她是一位职业人类学家，她花了很多时间与矿工们在一起，比如真正和他们一起深入矿井。
Mining has a very strong culture and I think the reason is because people who work underground are well aware of the fact that every day you go in, you don't know if you're coming out. The first time Cullen went down into a mine, she was told that she had to have something reflective on her hard hat. There's a lot of heavy machinery moving around, from buses to the shears, roof bolters, and other tools used to extract coal. People get hit, they get run over, they get crushed by mobile equipment. And so reflective material increases the visibility of the people underground. We put strips of reflective tape on the back of our hard hats, but then it became pretty obvious that other people had other things on their hard hats, and these were stickers.
“采矿业有着非常强烈的文化，我认为原因在于，在地下工作的人都非常清楚这样一个事实：你每天进去的时候，根本不知道自己还能不能活着出来。”库伦第一次下井时，有人告诉她，她的安全帽上必须贴有反光标识。有大量重型机械在四处移动，从运兵车到采煤机、锚杆机以及用于开采煤炭的其他工具。人们会被撞到、被碾压、被移动设备压碎。因此，反光材料增加了地下人员的可见度。我们在安全帽背面贴上了反光胶带条，但后来很明显，其他人安全帽上还有别的东西，那就是贴纸。
The stickers had originally been little advertisements that the manufacturers of mining equipment handed out. Even before the late 1960s, when mining safety laws started requiring reflective materials underground, miners used those stickers to stay visible to each other. But as time passed, the stickers evolved. They became more personal and started to tell miners stories. And the mine companies themselves started printing stickers for their workers. They went from simple ads to signaling and identity. These are sort of, they're symbols, symbols of the mining industry and that you're part of it, that you're a miner.
这些贴纸最初是采矿设备制造商派发的小广告。早在20世纪60年代末采矿安全法律开始强制要求在地下使用反光材料之前，矿工们就已经在使用这些贴纸来确保彼此可见。但随着时间推移，贴纸不断演变。它们变得更加个性化，开始讲述矿工们的故事。矿山企业自身也开始为员工印制贴纸。它们从简单的广告转变为信号和身份的象征。这些某种程度上可以说是符号，是采矿业的符号，代表着你是其中一员，代表着你是一名矿工。
After a year in the Alabama mine, Ronnie swapped out his yellow hardhat for a black one, which meant he was no longer a rookie. With that, came more stickers. The stickers always came in twos. One went on his hard hat, which he actually brought out to show me. So where's your six inches of reflective tape? I probably covered all mine up with stickers. You can see all the album stickers on it, you know? The other sticker he saved for his growing collection. A minor showed Ronnie how to keep the stickers organized, so each week he'd sit down and put the new stickers in an album.
在阿拉巴马的矿井工作了一年后，罗尼把他的黄色安全帽换成了黑色的，这意味着他不再是一个新手了。随之而来的，是更多的贴纸。这些贴纸总是成对出现。一张贴在他的安全帽上，他甚至把安全帽拿出来给我看。“那你那六英寸的反光胶带去哪儿了？”“我可能全用贴纸给盖上了。你能从上面看到所有的专辑贴纸，你知道的？”另一张贴纸则被他珍藏起来，丰富他的收藏。一位老矿工教罗尼如何将这些贴纸归类整理，于是他每周都会坐下来，把新的贴纸贴进一本纪念册里。
What's this one? That's the Grand Reaper, it looks like, don't you? keep the stickers organized. So each week he'd sit down and put the new stickers in an album. What's this one? That's the Graham Reaper, it looks like, don't it? It says UMWA, actually a union sticker. I'm sure it's got something to do with Black Long. Managers and the safety man at his mind gave him stickers with the mind name on them, and his union gave him stickers with union messages on them. One of his favorite stickers has the state of Alabama outlined in red, and inside it says, Alabama coal miner. That's kind of a pride thing, though. You know, Alabama coal miner.
“这个是什么？”“看起来像是死神，对吧？你得把贴纸整理好。所以每周他都会坐下来，把新贴纸放进纪念册里。这个是什么？看起来像死神，对吧？上面写着UMWA，其实是一张工人工会贴纸。我敢肯定这跟黑肺病有关。”他矿上的管理人员和安全员会发给他印有矿山名称的贴纸，他的工会则会发给他印有工会标语的贴纸。他最喜欢的贴纸之一上面用红色勾勒出了阿拉巴马州的轮廓，里面写着“阿拉巴马煤矿工人”。“这其实是一种充满自豪感的东西，你知道的。‘阿拉巴马煤矿工人’。”
As he gained more experience, he got stickers commemorating his accomplishments. He worked at a company early on that counted the amount of coal mined by the number of cars filled during a shift. Something like 100 cars was OK. But Ronnie has a sticker that says his team mined 150 cars in one shift. And then these stickers says 150 car club with a little playboy bunny on there. He also has one commemorating 225 cars in a shift,
随着经验越来越丰富，他得到了用来纪念自己成就的贴纸。他早期工作过的一家公司，是通过一个班次中装满煤炭的车数来统计采煤量的。大约100车就算可以了。但罗尼有一张贴纸，上面写着他的团队在一个班次里开采了150车。接着这些贴纸上写着“150车俱乐部”，上面还有一个小小的花花公子兔标志。他还拥有一个用来纪念单班次开采225车的贴纸，
which is a big deal. You can have a big run in the next night, you're outside and all the guys that didn't have such a good run or whatever and your boss is going around giving you these stickers and it was just kind of been a sin if thing. A number of major mind safety laws were passed in the US, and Elaine Cohen started working at a new agency that was responsible for studying and enforcing safety in the mines. For years, she researched mining culture. In the 2000s, the National Institute for Occupational Safety and Health of Federal Agency hired her to develop a safety training program for coal miners. By that time, she knew who she was dealing with. So she knew she might be facing some skepticism from the miners she was trying to reach. I don't look like a miner. I'm a woman,
这可是一件大事。“第二天晚上你可能就会有一场大丰收，你在井外，所有那些业绩没那么好或者怎么样的伙计们，还有你的老板会到处给你发这些贴纸，这感觉就像是一种带有象征意义的认可。”美国通过了一系列重大的矿山安全法规，伊莱恩·库伦开始在一个新机构工作，该机构负责研究和执行矿山安全标准。多年来，她一直在研究采矿文化。2000年代，联邦机构“国家职业安全与健康研究所”聘请她为煤矿工人开发安全培训项目。当时，她很清楚自己面对的是什么人。所以她知道，她可能会面临自己试图接触的矿工们的怀疑。“我看起来不像个矿工。我是个女性，”
and most of them are not. So getting them to work with me, especially when I was a representative of the federal government, and you know, they are a little dairty to, you know, work with the government. But Elaine had seen that the miners were really into these stickers, and she figured she could use them to gain their trust and to convey messages about safety. But she knew just putting work safe on a sticker wouldn't cut it. She needed something to grab the miners' attention.
“而且他们大多数都不是。所以要让他们配合我的工作，尤其是当我作为联邦政府代表的时候，你知道的，他们对跟政府打交道其实有点提防。”但伊莱恩发现矿工们对这些贴纸非常痴迷，她琢磨着可以利用这一点来赢得他们的信任，并传达有关安全的讯息。不过她知道，仅仅在贴纸上写上“注意工作安全”是远远不够的。她需要能吸引矿工注意力的大招。
We were working out in Eastern Kentucky. It was a mining community with deep cultural ties to coal, and she started to notice something. She'd be walking along with the safety guy. And as we would approach another miner, he would squeal like a pig. I finally asked him, I said, Jesse, what's going on here? Why are they doing that? And he said, oh, they're just saying they know I'm a coalhog. And I said, what is a coalhog? And he's a coalhog is hungry for coal, greedy for coal.
“当时我们在肯塔基州东部工作。那是一个与煤炭有着深厚文化纽带的采矿社区，她开始注意到一件事。她会和安全员一起散步。”“当我们靠近另一个矿工时，他会像猪一样尖叫。我最后问他，我说：‘杰西，这到底是怎么回事？他们为什么那样做？’他说：‘哦，他们只是在说他们知道我是个煤精（coalhog）。’我说：‘什么是煤精？’他说煤精就是对煤渴望、对煤贪婪的人。”
Can't ever get enough. Meaning that you're a good minor. So Elaine took the idea and designed a sticker with a big muscular pig with a hard hat on, and it says coalhogs work safe. So what we were doing is putting those two ideas together, that you can be a coalhog, but you can also work safely. The miners loved it. Oh gosh, I think we printed 3,000 to begin with, and I have I have one little packet left that I'm kind of keeping as a you know, keep safe. Some of Colin's other designs were duds. Her team made one with a dead canary. Canaries were once used to check for bad air in a mine, but that was a long time ago, and the younger miners didn't get it. Other stickers catering to
“永远也挖不够。意思就是你是个好矿工。”于是伊莱恩采用了这个创意，设计了一张贴纸，上面画着一只戴着安全帽、肌肉健硕的猪，写着“煤精安全工作”。所以我们当时做的事情，就是把这两个概念结合起来：你既可以是个煤精，但你同时也能安全工作。矿工们爱死这个设计了。“噢天哪，我想我们一开始印了3000张，我现在手头还留着一小包，打算当作某种纪念品留着。”库伦的其他一些设计则反响平平。她的团队曾设计过一张印有死金丝雀的贴纸。金丝雀曾被用来检测矿井中的不良空气，但那是很久以前的事了，年轻的矿工们并不理解这个梗。其他迎合
the raunchy humor in the mines didn't pass muster with her bosses in the federal government. For example, they designed one sticker to remind miners to check for gas in the mines. So, this one was at the back end of a donkey and had the donkey kind of looking back at you and it said, don't be an ass, check for gas. And kind of had this little cloud coming out. Gas can be really dangerous underground and donkeys were once used to carry coal out of the mines. No, oh boy, the folks in Washington didn't like that one, but the miners loved it.
矿井里低俗幽默的贴纸也没有通过联邦政府上司的审查。例如，他们曾设计过一张贴纸，用来提醒矿工检查矿井中的瓦斯。所以，这张贴纸画的是一头驴的屁股后面，驴还回过头来看你，上面写着：“别像个驴一样蠢，检查瓦斯。”旁边还飘着一团小小的云雾。地下瓦斯可能非常危险，而驴过去曾被用来把煤从矿井里拉出来。“不，噢天哪，华盛顿的官员们可不喜欢这个，但矿工们却爱不释手。”
Unless Elaine visited your mine, it'd be hard to get one of these stickers. A lot of the stickers were specialized or localized depending on what organization or company designed them. That's part of what made collecting them fun. I have over 26,000 different stickers in my collection. And I've kind of come to believe that you either are a collector or you're not. And if you're not a collector, you just don't get it. And if you are a collector, you just really can help yourself. This is Lenny Hanner.
除非伊莱恩亲自去过你的矿井，否则很难弄到这些贴纸。许多贴纸都是专门定制的，或者根据设计它们的组织或公司而带有浓厚的地方特色。这也是收集它们的一大乐趣所在。“我的收藏里有超过26,000张不同的贴纸。我渐渐开始相信，要么你是个收藏家，要么就不是。如果你不是收藏家，你根本不会懂。而如果你是个收藏家，你真的是完全无法克制自己。”这位是伦尼·汉纳。
And I'm a coal miner from Southern Illinois. Lenny has worked in coal mines for 40 years. He's a major sticker collector. At the height of his collecting in the 1980s, he'd exchanged stickers with other collectors across the country and go to sticker swaps almost every weekend. Those are meetups where miners exchanged pieces. Lenny says unique stickers were like currency in the mines, a way to buy or sell favors and help. For instance, say you're a trucker and you rolled up to the mines with a big load of supplies. You asked some of the miners to help you unload. The first thing they wanted to know is, do you have any stickers? Without stickers, the miners wouldn't exactly rush to help. So they all learned that they had stickers in that truck when they arrived, and that's
“我是来自伊利诺伊州南部的煤矿工人。”伦尼在煤矿工作了40年。他是一位重量级的贴纸收藏家。在20世纪80年代他收藏的鼎盛时期，他会与全国各地的其他收藏家交换贴纸，几乎每个周末都去参加贴纸交换会。那是矿工们交换藏品的聚会。伦尼说，独特的贴纸就像是矿井里的硬通货，是一种购买或出售人情和帮助的手段。比如，假设你是一名卡车司机，拉着满满一车物资来到矿上。你请一些矿工帮你卸货。他们问的第一件事就是：“你有贴纸吗？”如果没有贴纸，矿工们可不会急着去帮忙。所以他们一到那儿就都明白了卡车里有贴纸，而这样一来，
tend to get unloaded a whole lot faster that way. Lenny still works from mining company, but above ground these days. He lives in an old mining town and a house that was once owned by a mining company, and he's got a full room devoted to mining memorabilia. I'm married to the most understanding woman in the world. He keeps his stickers in 27 albums organized by type of sticker. The ones printed by mining companies, the ones equipment manufacturers gave out,
卸货的速度往往会变得快得多。伦尼现在仍然为矿业公司工作，不过如今是在地面上。他住在一个老矿区小镇的一栋曾属于矿业公司的房子里，他有一整间屋子专门用来存放采矿纪念品。“我娶了全世界最理解我的女人。”他把贴纸保存在27本按贴纸类型分类的纪念册里。矿业公司印制的贴纸、设备制造商派发的贴纸，
the ones focused on safety and union issues. Some of them are especially sentimental. I have a sticker that I got from a friend of mine and he recently passed away and I have just a couple stickers in my collection that really make me think of him when I see them. The sticker albums function just like photo albums, reminding minors of their milestones and stories. They are just little pieces of our history, of our past little momentos. I guess maybe like a postcard if you travel that you might pick up a postcard that reminds you of something from the past. We can just see our past mining history there on the pages of the album.
以及聚焦于安全和工会问题的贴纸。其中有些具有特别的情感价值。“我有一张从朋友那儿得到的贴纸，他最近去世了，我的收藏里只要有那么几张贴纸，每当我看到它们，就会立刻想起他。”这些贴纸册就像照片册一样，提醒着矿工们他们的里程碑和故事。它们只是我们历史、我们过去的微小碎片，小小的纪念品。我想也许就像你旅行时可能会买一张明信片，它能让你想起过去的某些事情。我们只需翻开相册的页面，就能看到我们过去的采矿历史。
Of course, just like with photos, some of the darker memories don't end up in the album. In 2011, after more than 30 years in the mines, my partner's dad Ronnie had an accident. We were living a thousand miles away and paced around in my living room as news trickled in. We eventually learned that his hand got pulled into a machine, and it took a finger. Down in Alabama, he was rushed to a hospital. He was told to call his wife, Deborah. At first, he didn't want to call, what happened in the mine stayed in the mine, but the nurse insisted, and Deborah happened to be nearby.
当然，就像照片一样，一些较为黑暗的记忆并没有被收进相册里。2011年，在矿井里工作了30多年后，我伴侣的父亲罗尼遭遇了一次事故。当时我们住在千里之外，随着消息一点点传进耳朵，我在起居室里焦急地踱来踱去。我们最终得知，他的手被卷进了一台机器里，断了一根手指。在阿拉巴马州，他被紧急送往医院。有人叫他给他的妻子黛博拉打个电话。起getStatusCode初，他并不想打，矿井里发生的事就留在矿井里，但护士坚持要打，而黛博拉恰好就在附近。
I remember Deborah looking at me when she came in the room and said, Ronnie, Johnson, how did you get so dirty? You know, like, I mean, I'd been getting that wife for years. And I guess she had never saw me. I had on my rubber boots and my face was all black and my hand was all wrapped up in the bandage. He'd never really shared much about his life in the mind with his family. I guess they had never saw me like that. I didn't tell them what I went through.
“我记得黛博拉走进房间时看着我说：‘罗尼·约翰逊，你怎么弄得这么脏？’你知道的，我的意思是，我多年来一直以那种妻子般的视角在生活。我猜她从没见过那样的我。我穿着橡胶靴，脸全黑了，手也被绷带紧紧包裹着。”他从未真正向家人多谈起他在矿井里的生活。“我猜他们从来没见过我那个样子。我没有告诉他们我经历了什么。”
The sticker albums stacked up in his cozy house, only tell their stories to those who know how to read them. Ronnie says before he lost his finger, he'd gone 31 years without spending a night in the hospital. He'd never written in an ambulance, and never had an accident in the mind that made him lose work hours. I called up for all those 31 years and one night, you know. Ronnie never got a sticker for that.
这些堆在他温馨家中的贴纸册，只向那些懂得如何解读它们的人诉说着它们的故事。罗尼说，在他失去手指之前，他曾连续31年没有在医院过夜。他从未坐过救护车，也从未在矿井里发生过导致他损失工作时间的事故。“我为了那连续31年付出了代价，结果在一个晚上就……你知道的。”罗尼从来没有因为那件事得到过一张贴纸。
So what do you do with a mind that's no longer productive? Lots of things that turns out. Kohlstedt tells us about his favorite examples of adaptive reuse after this. We were attracted to the coal miner stickers because it was this cool way that design and the culture of mining intersected and it brought to mind another interesting juxtaposition of design and abandoned minds that Colestead wrote about on the website, So I asked him to come in the studio and talk about it. I think a lot of people tend to have this idea that minds are these, you know, rickety, dangerous places to go, you know, with rotting timber frames holding up sections of tunnel
那么，面对一个不再具备产值的矿井，你能做些什么呢？事实证明，有很多事情可做。接下来，科尔斯塔将为我们讲述他最喜欢的适应性再利用案例。我们之所以被煤矿工人的贴纸吸引，是因为这是设计与采矿文化交织的一种酷炫方式，它让我们想起了科尔斯塔在网站上写过的设计与废弃矿井之间另一个有趣的并置现象，所以我请他来到录音室聊聊这个话题。我认为很多人往往有这样一种印象，觉得矿井都是那些摇摇晃晃、充满危险的地方，你知道的，里面有用腐烂的木头框架支撑着的隧道段，
that could collapse on you at any moment. The reality is a lot of minds are much bigger than that and much more stable than that and really have promising futures Doing much different things than they were designed for was a good example So one example would be there's this really cool mine in Romania that was actually first mind for salt Nearly a thousand years ago and it's been used on an office of salt mine ever since so it's really deep and it's really complex And recently they decided we're gonna turn this into an attraction. So they made it a museum, they made it kind of a theme park,
随时可能在你头顶坍塌。现实情况是，许多矿井要比这大得多，也稳定得多，并且有着光明的未来，它们正在从事与最初设计截然不同的事情，这就是一个很好的例子。所以其中一个例子是，罗马尼亚有一个非常酷的矿井，它最初在将近一千年前是为了开采盐矿而开凿的，从那以后它一直被用作盐矿，所以它非常深，结构也非常复杂。最近他们决定：我们要把这里变成一个旅游景点。于是他们把它变成了一个博物馆，把它打造成了一种主题公园，
you can go down there and like, boat around on the swatter and the pictures are just sort of mesmerizing. They've really lit this place up. So you can go down and really give a sense of the geology but also just have this kind of fun experience underground. Cool. Are there any in the US? Yeah, in Kansas, there's a data center.
你可以下到井里，比如在这些水面上划船拍照，那些画面简直让人着迷。他们真的把这个地方点亮了。所以你可以下去真切感受地质构造，同时也能在地下获得这种充满趣味的体验。太酷了。美国有这样的矿井吗？有的，在堪萨斯州，有一个数据中心。
It's a little less exciting, but a little more functional on a sort of data-to-day basis that essentially uses the natural, you know, even temperatures and the protection of this mind space, old limestone mind space, to how is it servers? And you can imagine, you know, if you're just trying to keep these servers running, you know, during any kind of weather, the perfect place is just to tuck them on the ground. Yeah, I mean, that makes a ton of sense to me.
它虽然没那么刺激，但在日常运营层面却更加实用，它基本上是利用天然的恒温条件以及这个矿井空间（一个旧石灰岩矿井空间）的保护来托管服务器？你可以想象一下，如果你只是想让这些服务器在任何天气下都能持续运转，最完美的地方就是把它们藏在地下。对，我的意思是，这对我来说完全说得通。
And there's also a research facility that is doing experiments on dark matter, far underground in South Dakota in an old gold mine. It's about a mile deep. And it turns out that there's a lot of particles that sort of just float through space and bombard our atmosphere on a pretty regular basis and Getting below the surface they can get away from a lot of that noise and have a lot more of a kind of clean experiment. Yeah, totally. Yeah That makes a ton of sense. Well, that's so cool. Yeah, and you know if they decided to destroy the universe at least they're a mile underground Yeah, I mean yeah, right? I hope the hope is that they'd only just destroy their lab and amount or something. Right. Well, there you go.
还有一个研究设施正在南达科他州的一座废弃金矿地下深处进行暗物质实验。它大约有一英里深。事实证明，有大量粒子会在太空中四处飘荡，并相当有规律地轰击我们的大气层，而深入地下，他们就可以避开很多那类噪声，从而获得更纯净的实验环境。完全没错。对。这完全说得通。哇，太酷了。对啊，而且你知道的，如果他们决定毁灭宇宙，至少他们是在地下一英里深的地方。对，我的意思是，对吧？希望他们只会炸掉他们的实验室和一座山之类的东西。没错。好吧，就是这样。
So what's your favorite example? So my favorite is probably the Louisville Mega Cabern, which is this huge, huge underground space in Louisville, Kentucky. If you buy the argument that it's now a building, it's the largest building in Kentucky at about four million square feet. And basically this mine opened in the 1930s. The dugout limestone for decades, really carved this thing out.
那么你最喜欢的例子是什么？我最喜欢的可能是路易斯安那超级洞穴（Louisville Mega Cavern），这是位于肯塔基州路易斯安那的一个巨大无比的地下空间。如果你接受“它现在是一座建筑”这个说法，它大约有四百万平方英尺，是肯塔基州最大的建筑。基本上这个矿井是在20世纪30年代开业的。几十年来，人们一直在那里开采石灰岩，真正把这个地方掏空了。
In the 1960s, they actually talked about using it. It's a fallout shelter in case the Cuban Missile Crisis went the wrong way. And they were planning to pack like tens of thousands of people in there. And then eventually it sort of fell into discus. And some investors came along and said, hey, we could do something with this. And they did.
在20世纪60年代，他们甚至讨论过要利用它。如果古巴导弹危机朝错误的方向发展，它就可以用作防空洞。他们当时正计划把成千上万的人塞进里面。后来它就逐渐荒废了。然后一些投资者出现了，他们说：嘿，我们可以用这个地方做点什么。于是他们真的做了。
Basically they bought this thing. And they started putting businesses in there. They started using it for storage because it's sort of, you know, temperature stable. It's a good place for storage. And then they did something kind of weird. And they started adding all all these kind of theme park elements to it. So you can go take tram tours of the underground,
基本上他们买下了这个地方。然后他们开始把各种企业引进到里面。他们开始用它来做仓储，因为它基本上，你知道的，温度稳定。这是个搞仓储的好地方。接着他们做了一件有点奇特的事。他们开始往里面添加各种主题公园的元素，所以你可以去参加地下的电车之旅，
you can go take zipline tours, there's a ropes course. At the heart of it all, one of the biggest functions is this huge, huge 300,000 plus square foot bike park. And it's like a BMX bike park with like a yellows and jumps and all that stuff. And they build those out of all the sort of fill that was already carved out and sort of laying around from the minors, right? So all they have to do is just kind of pick up the dirt here, shovel it over there, and
你可以去玩滑索之旅，里面还有绳网攀爬课程。而这一切的核心，其中最大的功能就是这个占地巨大、超过30万平方英尺的自行车公园。它就像是一个BMX小轮车公园，里面有各种土坡和跳跃点之类的东西。而且它们全是用那些原本就已经被开采出来、堆在矿井各处的矿渣废料搭建出来的，对吧？所以他们所需要做的，就是把这里的泥土铲起来，搬到那边去，
they can make entirely new courses. Oh, it's so cool. Yeah. And we have some pictures of these on our website. Oh, yeah, we've got a bunch of pictures and some video of this on the website. Awesome. Well, thanks so much. That's so cool. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Arina Jeroff with Delaney Hall, Tech Production and Mixed by Sri Fusaf, Music by Sean Rial. Our senior editor is Katie Mingle. Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
然后他们就能建造出全新的赛道。噢，太酷了。对啊。我们的网站上有这些照片。哦，对的，我们在网站上有一大堆照片和一些视频。太棒了。好的，非常感谢。真是太酷了。本周的“99%隐形”由伊琳·若罗夫与德兰妮·霍尔共同制作，技术制作与混音来自斯里·富萨夫，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔提供。我们的资深编辑是凯蒂·明格尔。库特·科尔斯塔是数字总监。
Rest of the staff is Avery Trouffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of radio-topia at 91.7Kale, W. San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row. In Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. You can find 99% of visible and joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PIorg, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our beautiful home on the internet, with more design stories than we could ever tell you inside this podcast is our website, 99PI.org.
其余的工作人员还有埃弗里·特鲁夫曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、特伦·马扎，以及我，罗曼·马斯。我们是位于旧金山91.7兆赫的Radiotopia广播网络的一个项目，制作地点位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的广播街。你可以在Facebook上找到“99%隐形”并参与有关节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（@Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PIorg），也可以在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上找到我们。但我们在互联网上美丽的家，那个拥有比我们在本播客中讲述的更多的设计故事的地方，是我们的网站：99PI.org。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。